dan Ryan thanks for coming by you're
showing us paper-bound this is on ps4
this is the first time anyone's ever
seen it on ps4 is that right the first
time that's been you know broadcast on
the internet otherwise on the ps4
that's pretty sweet and I know I saw
this last year on PC but it's bit
different this time
not too many suite next-gen console
games like this you can definitely
compare it to kind of like a samurai gun
or towerfall this is absolute
pandemonium
beat them up right now we're all playing
in kind of like a free-for-all mode but
what's really cool about this game
people are probably starting to notice
is that it is gravity based you can
change gravity so it's kind of like what
I think is something that makes this
game pretty unique and different
I keep suiciding now it's really hard to
play in this game you said I'm coming
out in February of 2015 is that correct
yeah like February 2015
ps4 in steam it's gonna be $9.99 so you
know a pretty good deal for for friends
hours of fun sweet we'll definitely have
to take a look at some of the other
modes besides the one in which I am
getting my butt whooped you can do
capture the quill which is basically
capture the flag but since it's all
paper themed do you have a quill nice
touch and okay so I'm on the red team
who else is on the red team on the right
oh I think that's me I'm gonna be 18
though yeah we got this alright sound
off on what you are I'm gonna be skull
soldier I'm gonna be Ninh jetty I'm
Eddie classic
I'm Jasmine why not see the most okay
okay yeah you guys ready I'm ready
I played this level it's okay I'm ready
my body's good I'm all right I'm glad
you did Oh No stop him oh yeah point BAM
I'm going on a potato oh yes oh nice
nice shot oh that's right I'm a ninja
yeah killed I need to be on D
oh thank that bond well nice
oh yeah we're just doing a flag running
now we're a flag running duty so
stressful
yeah it's are you scored yeah run away
oh thanks for the scissors all right
yeah I guess you [ __ ] way that's right
no bummer let's do another for all this
for whatever reason I have read Dante's
Inferno then that's what we should go
yeah it's it's pretty vivid like the
descriptions of everything are pretty
intense I'll be Eddie I mean character
he's a stick man comes to life in
adventures into all these old books Quan
one why we cut it just so we're doing
free-for-all we're doing survival mode
which is like you know stock using smash
bros terms you get three lives and then
you're out okay
there's my breath yeah especially in the
inferno max so we'll play that I even
know oh not this map looking at the
landscape there the the real estate okay
the ribs were bad this is C this is
exponentially worse I'm already out this
is not good yeah down didn't wait for
the bombs
both have bombs
oh yeah oh and again it's down to this
all right like these deathmatch ones
let's do this I'll do one of my
favorites I just love the layout it has
a lot of different avenues you can take
feel like love memes I'm really good at
this map how's it gonna take oh no you
why do you have a huge hammer alright no
runnin nice yeah
somehow the ultimate the underdog it's a
Cinderella story is this a replay or
yeah it is that's pretty cool you wanted
one you can actually like fast-forward
rewind with some triggers all its sweet
film that killing blow what this is you
can also see my fear right here this is
when the screaming happened and then I
got lucky right here I got cocky it was
I'll remember that forever Oh squish oh
stop it
there's something really powerful in
this where like entire fold the items
help you so much but if you are greedy
and you go for the items more than
you're thinking about your surroundings
you will die trying to get
those items and I swear in this game
it's like no different if you have
scissors you get so distracted by the
[ __ ] of scissors that you end up
getting killed
I love debate people like I'll leave
some sister sitting somewhere I'll wait
there so I'm gonna go for oh man they
just BAM I get them there and I haven't
looking yeah like I hope the trigger
down I get my bomb ready and then
whenever and then you're about to throw
it and then scissors just like come out
of nowhere stay away from me marry same
Matt but in the classic mode so still
free fraud by instead of stock it's like
the thing where you get to ten and then
the tear opens okay yeah it's nice to
see another like kind of like a wind
mechanic not just like killing yeah it
gives out everyone else a way to stop
them yeah all right sound off on who you
pick um Goblin King so do they I'm the
Guardian did they hit let me defend my
egyptian realm the hitboxes actually
mattered cuz I swear BBB looks like way
bigger than like let's say the bird guy
in the bottom-right corner they all have
the same size oh really okay do they
have yeah is there any difference at all
just purely a study okay okay
yeah all right let's all just agree to
kill the hublin I didn't mean it
oh nice oh yeah Bonnie took scissors to
the face oh nice
the old runaway and throw the scissor
are you doing up there don't mind my
shot don't mind my sneaky a lot of work
to get into that
oh you bombs I'm like that president who
died in 30 days every time I have the
King I die immediately I never get to
enjoy my king it's in those moments of
quiet bliss where you really can hear
how upset everyone is oh no now die yeah
yeah that's not green oh why is this on
your name on it
I see me are you slicing me when oh nice
shot
every time everybody leaves Oh
Yahtzee I lost a year of my life
wow that was Regan alright so but this
game is coming out in February of 2015
so that was awesome thank you guys so
much for coming down and showing us this
weekend oh thank you he's so smug